[Musique]
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
Jean-Michel Arnaud et d'être avec nous
pendant cette demi-heure vous êtes élu
des Hautes Alpes membbres du groupe
Union centriste et je le disais
rapporteur du budgets des collectivités
territoriales on va bien sûr en parler
dans quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité elle concerne beaucoup les
questions d'immigration il y a beaucoup
de textes en ce moment au Parlement sur
le sujet et hier il y avait le texte des
républiques qui était discuté à
l'Assemblée nationale c'était la niche
parlementaire des députés c'est-à-dire
que c'est eux qui choisissaient l'ordre
du jour la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui vise notamment à
demander un référendum sur l'immigration
en élargissant le champ de l'article 11
et à demander également la primauté du
droit national sur le droit européen sur
ces questions migratoires c'est un texte
qui divise la majorité sénatoriale vous
les centristes vous vous y êtes opposé
sur ces sujets en commission pourquoi
nous avons une position constante
au sein de la majorité sénatoriale il n
a aucune surprise la position de l'Union
centriste portée par Philippe boncarer
nous nous y opposons essentiellement non
pas sur l'esprit qu'il faille donner une
réponse aux attentes des Français en
matière d'immigration nous sommes
conscients qu'il y a des attentes fortes
dans le pays pour une meilleure
régulation aux frontières d'abord
européennes et puis l'impact que cela
peut avoir à l'intérieur notamment de
l'Hexagone mais pas que y compris à
Mayotte notre elle est extrêmement
simple à expliquer nous ne souhaitons
pas que la France pays fondateur de
l'Union
européenne particulièrement
attaché aux valeurs du droit mett en
place une sorte de frexit
constitutionnel qui consisterait à dire
que sur un certain nombre de sujets la
France se mettrait à l'écar de l'Union
européenne et finalement ne respecterait
pas les traités ne respecterait pas la
convention qui nous liit aux autres pays
de l'Union européenne mais mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui l'Union européenne c'est
pas un frein au contrôle de la politique
migratoire ben pardonnez-moi l'Union
européenne devrait être l'outil
principal de contrôle des flux
migratoire d'ailleurs que ce soit les
accords de Dublin que ce soit les
dispositifs mis en place avec Frontex
devrait y concourir la difficulté mais
de vrai vous le dites bien il y a des
difficultés dans l'Union européenne à se
mettre d'accord sur ce sujet je suis élu
d'un département frontalier euh les
Hautes Alpes frontières avec le piément
italien euh dans la pratique quand
j'entends et écoute les policiers quand
j'écoute les autorités administratives
de proximité euh et que je vois
effectivement que la relation avec notre
pays voisin l'Italie pour la gestion des
flux migratoires n'est pas très
opérationnelle et toujours opérationnel
cela pose effectivement question mais
c'est c'est plus une question non pas de
droit européen une question de pratique
avec le pays voisin donc je je je crois
que il ne faut pas confondre l'objectif
avec le moyen le moyen c'est de rester
pour ce qui nous concerne dans le cadre
du pacte européen les centristes ont
toujours eu une filiation européenne
forte je ne vais pas faire appel aux
grandes figures du centrisme que sont
Simon veille notamment et d'autres nous
sommes constant sur sur ce sujet
géraldmanan juste hier il a dit au
républicains il les accusé de double
frexit européen et constitutionnel vous
diriez la même chose pour ce qui
concerne le deuxième sujet qui est
l'élargissement du champ référendaire à
des questions de société qui pourra
aller jusque à l'immigration enfin là
aussi je crois que si les questions
d'immigration se résolvaent par une
question référendaire qui par nature
génère une réponse par oui ou par non ça
saurait on est dans une complexité
extérieur à l'Union européenne avec les
conventions qui nous lient avec des pays
tiers on parlera peut-être de l'Algérie
dans qu euh mais euh mais aussi des des
questions de mobilisation à l'exérie de
nos frontières euh pour mobiliser la
répartition aussi de tous les pays pour
la répartition des des des immigrés qui
arrivent parce que derrière immigrés il
y a plusieurs formes d' a les réfugiés
politiques il y a également des réfugiés
climatiques bientôt nous avons également
l'immigration totalement illégale qui
doit être combattu et puis il y a les
procédures franco-françaises aussi de
gestion des demandes et de traitement
des demandes d'asile qui doivent être
raccourci c'était l'esprit d'ailleurs de
la loi immigration portée par le
gouvernement et Gérald dermanin qui
devait notamment assouplir tous ces
éléments je crois que ce qu'il faut
c'est de la cohérence ne pas tomber dans
le populisme en disant il y a qu' il
faut un référendum oui pardon on aura
réglé le problème le populisme consiste
à dire on on fait des murs un trumpis B
la française qui consisterait à faire
des murs à nos frontières et on a réglé
le problème je pense qu'il faut de la
concertation il faut de la discussion
avec nos partenaires intérieurs à
l'Europe et retravailler sur les
conventions avec les pays-tiers et il
faut bien évidemment des règles de droit
parce qu'on est aussi garant d'un modèle
démocratique qui est vous le savez
attaqué de toutes parts y compris par
celles et ceux qui parfois mettent le
curseur très loin je pense notamment aux
extrêmes qui voudraient effectivement
tout ça éclate pour avoir une vision
très nationaliste des sujets mais du
coup les républicains risquent fortement
d'être mis en minorité au moment de
l'examen de ce texte en séance puisque
vous l'avez détricoté en commission
est-ce que ça risque de laisser des
traces dans la majorité sénatoriale
écoutez moi je crois que je fais
confiance à Bruno rotaillot Hervé
Marseille sous la houlette du
bienveillant efficace Gérard Larché pour
encore travailler peut-être à à des
accords je crois que la personne n'est
surpris de la position des centristes
depuis le premier jour nos partenaires
de la majorité sénatoriale savent que
sur ces sujetsl nous avons des marqueurs
voilà une majorité sénatoriale elle
marche sur deux pieds et c'est c'est la
force du dialogue entre nos forces
politiques et entre celles et ceux qui
les dirigent que de trouver des points
d'accord et des convergenence laissons
encore le dialogue s'effectuer et puis
si rien ne bouge nous serons constants
sur notre position vous en parliz les
républicains hier ont également fait
examiner un texte qui vise à dénoncer
l'accord franco-algérien de 1968 qui
donne aux algérien un statut particulier
favorable en matière de circulation de
séjour d'emploi en France il a été
rejeté par les les députés vous l'auriez
voté vous moi je pense que je l'aurais
voté pour d'abord je ne suis pas député
donc je suis sénateur oui oui non mais
est-ce que vous l'auriez voté si un tel
texte é présenté au Sénat qu'il faille
requestionner cet accord euh ce parit
nécessaire d'ailleurs je le rappelle
cela a été révisé cet accord a été
révisé à trois reprises de 1985 à 2001
et donc si cet accord a été renégocié
c'est que il est nécessaire qu'il le
soit encore il n'est pas normal que dans
les relations que nous avons avec les
pays du Maghreb pour la plupart d'entre
eux francophones qui ont une histoire
commune avec la France il y ait des
discussion qui soit de nature différente
avec un paystiers qui n'a pas cette
culture commune cette histoire commune
une histoire compliquée avec l'Algérie
mais me paraît effectivement nécessaire
de de discuter avec l'Algérie mais pour
vous ça doit se faire dans la discussion
avec le gouvernement algérien et pas
dans la dénonciation comme l'ont fait
les rép je P ça do dans la discussion à
condition qu'il y ait discussion je
crois savoir que est envisagé ça a été
annoncé par la première ministre la
visite du président algérien début 2024
sous réserve de ses
propres difficultés internes puisqu'il y
a une élection présidentielle en
décembre 2024 et se pose la question de
savoir si'il pourra se représenter
elisabethor a dit que la renégociation
est à l'ordre du jour mais Renaissance
hier a rejeté le texte des républiqus
vous comprenez la logique mais la
logique est s'il y a une rénégociation
qui est engagée pour peu que ce soit pas
de la poudre de de perlin pinpin que ce
soit pas effectivement une façon euh de
de rejeter le texte à l'air pour ne pas
traiter le problème et et procrastiner
une nouvelle fois une nouvelle fois sur
ce sujet je crois que ce qu'il faut
simplement dire c'est que les Algériens
doivent avoir probablement des
conditions d'accès au pays pour des
questions y compris de relations
familiales fortes entre une grande
partie de la communauté algérienne de
France et le pays d'origine euh bien
évidemment on ne peut pas avoir les
mêmes règles qui s'appliquent à
l'Algérie au au pays-tiers mais elles
doivent évoluer parce que grosso modo je
vous le dis comme je le pense euh pour
euh pour nous Français euh l'accès à
notre pays ne doit pas être un open bar
euh futtile pour les pour nos amis
algériens donc il faut qu'on rediscute
cela en niveau en nombre de quotas euh
sur les conditions également de séjour
et des titres de séjour touristiques des
titres de séjours surtout liés au
travail euh et que naturellement si on
discute avec tout le monde pour essayer
de réguler davantage les FS migratoires
on doit aussi discuter avec les algérien
donc la première ministre nous dit
grosso modo laissez-moi un peu de temps
pour discuter si effectivement à l'issue
euh euh du premier semestre 2024 les
choses ne bougent pas je pense qu'on on
devra changer de position et être
beaucoup plus dur avec le gouvernement à
cet effet sur le projet de loi
immigration il arrive en séance lundi à
l'Assemblée la version sénatoriale a été
détricotée par les les députés malgré ce
que dit Gérald armmanin ce matin dans ni
ce matin o où il dit finalement qu'il y
a beaucoup de choses qui ont été gardées
du texte du Sénat mais quand même sur
plusieurs points et notamment les points
cruciaux la question de l'aide médicale
d'État la question de la régularisation
des titres dans les métiers en tension
le l'Assemblée nationale est revenu
dessus est-ce que vous le regrettez moi
ce que je regrette c'est la perspective
rien n'est jamais acquis hein on ne sait
pas comment comment tout ça va retomber
euh mais rien ne serait plus
détestable que pour les institutions
mais aussi pour la perception que les
Françaises et Français ont nos
institutions de ne pas trouver un accord
sur un sujet aussi sensible euh il y a
une attente de réponse à l'angoisse aux
inquiétudes que peuvent avoir nos
concitoyens et et aussi parfois les
violents
que nos concit citoyens ressentent li au
fait migratoire vrai ou faux dans tous
les cas c'est un ressenti qui est réel
une réponse législative le le le
gouvernement a besoin de nouveaux outils
pour notamment traiter un certain nombre
de situation qui ont fait j'ose pas les
rappeler tellement elles sont
douloureuses pour pour les Français qui
ont fait l'objet de fait divers
monstrueux ces dernières semaines des
attaques terroristes des situations de
difficulté d'expulsion d'un certain
nombre de de criminels terroristes qui
ne peuvent pas être expulsé parce que
sont sur territoire national ou avant
l'âge de 13 ans nous avons également sur
l'aide médicale d'État une position du
Sénat qui n'était pas de supprimer une
aide médicale mais la transformé en aide
médicale d'urgence pour réduire le
spectre et faire en sorte que l'on
envoie aussi un signe non seulement aux
personnes qui veulent venir en France
pas pour être accompagné médicalement
mais pour avoir un autre destin d'autres
horizons d'autres perspectives de vie
mais qui bénéficient de ce dispositif
alors qu'un certain nombre de Français
disent on en fait trop donc je pense
qu'il faut trouver vous dites il y a un
problème d'acceptabilité sociale sur
cette question de l'aide médicale d'État
attention oui pour parti et il y a une
nécessité de détendre et d'objectiver le
débat sur l'immigration ce que nous
avons par le débat au Sénat je pense qui
a été quand même de bon niveau
globalement avec une amélioration du
texte avec un durcissement du texte par
rapport à son
nous avons fait ce travail donc
maintenant moi ce que je vise juste
pardon Jean-Michel sur cette question de
l'aide médicale d'État que vous avez
transformé en aide médicale d'urgence
Géral armanin ce matin dans le quotidien
ni ce matin il dit que ce sujet n'a pas
sa place dans le texte parce que ça
aurait été un cavalier législatif
retoqué par Conseil constitutionnel mais
il ferme pas la porte à un débat en
court terme sur cette question de la
transformation en Amu il dit la porte
n'est pas fermée est-ce que vous vous le
voyez comme une main tendue comme un
signe ce que je crois c'est que géralen
depuis le premier jour tente de trouver
les moyens de faire voter son texte euh
il y a un jeu aussi politique au sein du
gouvernement 493 pas 493 qui arrivera à
passer un texte aussi puissant et aussi
attendu dans l'opinion publique sans
passer sans passer par le 493 on voit
très bien qu'il y a aussi un peu des des
jeux sur l'après séquence mais au-delà
de ça qui est un jeu politicien gerérald
Manin a a eu la force de d'être très
présent au Sénat pour défendre son texte
à
généré je crois des des des échanges
fructueux il a souvent dit oui à toutes
sortes de propositions pour convaincre
bien moi ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on
puisse avoir une discussion CMP donc
commion il y aura un accord entre
députés sénateur je souhaite qu'il y ait
un vote quels qu'en soient les termes à
l'Assemblée nationale parce qu'il serait
quand même incroyable que sur un texte
tant attendu par la société française
tant observver aussi par nos partenaires
européens l'Assemblée nationale un ne
débattent que partiellement ou termine
ce débat là par un 493 donc ça c'est un
message au al parce qu'on sait il y aura
une motion de rejet préalable qui sera
examiné lundi si la vote elle pourrait
passer VO responsité c'est la
responsabilité nos partenaires de la
majorité sénatorial à l'air ont fait le
choix de faire des propositions
exigeantes et nous avons eu un texte
exigeant et
recalant finalement le barissant de ce
texte en lien avec les exig de la
population les attentes de la population
je dis simplement que l'Assemblée
nationale si j'avais un conseil à donner
à mes collègues députés étudier le texte
faire des contreopositions voter un
texte le vôre et on se rencontre en CMP
je crois que les se sénateurs et les se
députés qui se réuniraient dans une CMP
sont capables de trouver des
convergences pour montrer aux français
qu'on s'occupe de leur problème on va
parler de ce qui se passe au Sénat
puisque le Sénat poursuit l'examen du
budget cette semaine a été examiné le
budget des collectivités territoriales
dont vous êtes le rapporteur on va voir
ça avec Quentin
calm
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour Aran bonjourich
bon et Quentin à l'occasion de l'examen
de ce budget des collectivités locales
les sénateurs ont voté le retour de la
fameuse réserve parlementaire voilà la
réserve parlementaire souvenez-vous
avant 2017 avant la loi pour la
confiance dans la vie politique c'est
comme ça que ça'appelait le texte à
l'époque la réserve parlementaire
permettait de flécher des financements
du ministère de l'intérieur vers des
projets des Collectiv locales ou des
associations dans les départements en
2017 au moment de sa suppression au tout
début du quinquenat d'Emmanuel Macron
elle représentait 56 millions d'euros
pour les sénateurs 81 millions pour les
députés elle faisait polémique au moment
de sa suppression accusé d'être opaque
inégalitaire entre les parlementaires et
les circonscriptions ou les départements
mais pour les sénateurs cette réserve
permet de corriger les ratés de l'État
dans certains territoires et pour être
précis sur ce que vous vous avez
exactement voté cette semaine en séance
il s'agit de permettre aux
parlementaires de choisir les
bénéficiaires de 20 % de la DETR la D la
dotation d'équipement des territoires
ruraux cette DTR elle fait 1 milliard
d'euros dans le budget donc 20 % ça
représenterait 200 millions d'euros vous
pourriez flécher le gouvernement était
contre en séance regardez ce qu'a dit
Dominique fort la ministre des
collectivités locale elle a dit la
suppression de la réserve parlementaire
faisait partie du choc de confiance
voulu par le président Françis Hollande
vous pouvez tousser mais je vous le
rappelle je ne considère pas que le
rétablissement de la réserve participe à
à réconcilier nos concitoyens avec les
élus locaux et nationaux fin de citation
avec au passage une petite confusion de
la part de Dominique fort c'est bien
sous Emmanuel Macron à l'été 2017 que
cette modification a eu lieu on a alors
assisté à un débat assez vif en séance
les sénateurs ont même un peu refait le
débat de 2017 ils sont montés au créneau
assez en colère face aux arguments de la
min ministre Laurent Duplon a dit c'est
la technocratie administrative qui a
voulu supprimer la réserve parlementaire
parce que les baronniies locales elles
résistit justement à cette technocratie
administrative cet argument- là a fait
réagir un écologiste guimé roche surtout
le terme de baronnie locale qui lui a
pas plu il a dit les baronies sont un
danger mortel on nous l' nous on l'a vu
dans les Bouches du rô pour nos
concitoyens il ne faudrait pas que le P
que du PLF ressorte que le Sénat a
rétabli la réserve parlementaire patatra
regardez ce que titrait Public Sénat
cette semaine c'est bien ce que l'on
retient du vote de ce budget mais donc
Jean-Michel Arnaud pourquoi avoir
réinstauré une part de décisions
parlementaires dans les bénéficiaires de
cette Dr cette dotation pour les
communes rurales d'abord un petit rappel
de principe dans une période où les
Français sont très
attachés au respect des procédures à la
transparence France la réserve
parlementaire ce n'est pas une enveloppe
comme on entend parfois une enveloppe
parlementaire à disposition des élus
nationaux dans leur circonscription qui
distribuerait tel un ancien sénateur des
Hautes Alpes le baron de Rothschild dans
les années 30 40 une enveloppe avec des
billets qu'on coupe en deux contre je ne
sais quel avantage et attribution et
cetera non mais je le dis parce que le
terme envelopp voilà le terme enveloppe
ou réserve peut laisser penser que l'on
instaurerait une sorte de de de de
régime permettant de faire du
clientélisme des parlementairesdessus je
dis commment on s'adresse au plus grand
nombre je crois que c'est important de
de le rappeler donc je je réponds à
votre question euh d'abord les baronis
euh faut arê faut arrêter avec cette
dimension de dégradation de ce que
peuvent être les élus locaux et
parlementaires dans leur circonscription
euh nous sommes aussi la nation et euh
lorsque le préfet qui est un
fonctionnaire d'État réparti des crédits
DETR desciles dans son département en
aucun cas il est accusé
de faire du
clientélisme alors que j'ai déposé un
amendement qui a été d'ailleurs voté les
conditions notamment de gestion des
dossiers qui ne sont pas retenus ne font
pas l'objet d'une transparence totale à
l'égard des élus qui sont demandeurs
vous avez pas la justification lorsquun
préfit refuse une dotation à une commune
vous ne savez pas pourquoi le préfet ex
Il a M pas de pororté à connaissance y
compris parfois des motivations non
seulement au ma qui a demandé mais aussi
aux membres de la commission DETR du
département ainsi formé pour être
informé des conditions de répartition
des dites enveloppes deuxème observation
la réserve parlementaire avant 2017
était une réserve parlementaire qui
n'était pas un chéquier d'ailleurs les é
n'ont pas de chèque je le rappelle
n'était pas un chéquier donné au
parlementaires pour faire un chèque à un
élu ou à une association c'était un
dossier fléché par le parlementaire le
le bénéficiaire potentiel montait un
dossier transmis en préfecture qui était
instruit pour vérification de sa
légalité et de sa conformité aux règles
loi et règlements euh par le préfet des
services préfectoraux comme un dossier
DETR classique et ensuite il y avait un
fléchage sur la somme en question donc
le vrai débat il n'est pas à l'occasion
et là-dessus je suis assez d'accord avec
une partie de mes collègues du S j'étais
en séance quand on a débattu tout cela
euh ce n'est pas l'occasion d'un article
du PLF qu'on règle ce problème là il y a
une PPL alors justement on va y venir
parce que effectivement en plus avec le
493 le gouvernement va s'en sans aucun
doute supprimer cette modification qui a
été faite au Sénat sur la réserve
parlementaire en revanche effectivement
on va y revenir sur ce débat le 14
décembre prochain à l'occasion de
l'examen d'une proposition de loi
déposée par un de vos collègues
centristes le dispositif sera alors
beaucoup plus transparent que par le
passé effectivement avec des subventions
de 20000 € maximum mais alors quand même
comment garantir vous le disiez
vous-même le risque de clientélisme
lorsque et bien ces 20000 € seront
donnés à telle ou telle mairie moi je
vous dis les choses très simplement
j'avait commencé à raisonner sur le
travail actuel fait par un préfet
personne l'accuse de clientélisme euh or
on s'est très très bien que le préfet
analyse a des contacts aussi avec le
territoire et trouve ses équilibres
entre l'excellence du dossier et
l'équilibre territorial nécessaire pour
que tout le monde y retrouve ses petits
voilà donc lorsque un député ou un
sénateur aurait si la réserve
parlementaire était nouveau actionné à
attribuer des financements moi ce que je
souhaite c'est que d'abord on reprenne
les procédures antérieures à 2017
c'est-à-dire qu'il est constitution de
dossier gestion par les services pré
éctorau de la régularité que j'évoqué et
ce serait collégial pour les
parlementaires du département de la
circonscription ben je pense qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une discussion ou un
fléchage par parlementaire moi ça me
pose aucun problème ce sont des
modalités pratiques mais ce que je veux
dire simplement c'est que c'est
important de savoir que quand on fait la
tournée des maires ruraux en particulier
bien que les 137 millions de la réserve
parlementaire de 2017 ne soit plus on
est encore régulièrement interpellé par
les maires pour l'achat d'une
photocopieuse pour le financement d'AM
aménagement d'équipement de la crèche
alttegarderie du du quartier et il y a
très clairement sur les petits dossiers
qui concernent essentiellement les
petites communes un sujet du montant y
compris des aujourd'hui qui n'est
souvent pas attribué par les préfets
considérant que c'est un petit dossier
qui pourrait créer de la souplesse grâce
à la réserve parlementaire mais la
contrepartie de cela c'est la
transparence notamment pour les réseaux
associatifs et je n'oublie pas aussi
parce que disons les choses moi j'ai
l'habitude de parler cche qui a une
inquiétude contte tenu du fait que on a
un certain nombre de parlementaires qui
sont dans l'arc républicain ou pas euh
d'un certain nombre de nos collègues qui
sont modérés qui disent peut-être il
faudrait pas donner les moyens à un
certain nombre d'extrémistes de faire
campagne avec une forme de clientélme je
ne crois pas cet argument donc je le
débotte immédiatement si on met en place
un la transparence de un travail
d'instruction dans les services
préfectoraux et qu'on fait confiance à
la démocratie on devrait avancer sur ce
dossier dernière question ouais plus
généralement sur le budget examiné
mercredi de la relation avec les
collectivités territoriales vous parlez
dans votre rapport d'un environnement
qui demeure lourd d'incertitude pour les
collectivités territoriales vous
dénoncez le manque de marge de manœuvre
des collectivités locales il faut
redonner un impôt propre aux
collectivités ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que la tendance de ces dernières
années est une une tendance que je
conteste et je pense qui fait des des
dégâts dans les territoires la tendance
extrêmement simple c'est de dire aux
collectivités territoriales faites plus
et mieux on vous charge de gérer le
dernier kilomètre des Français et en
même temps on vous coupe le contrat qui
vous lie au français puisque vous ne
levez quasiment plus l'impôt et donc ça
devient très compliqué on a une
renationalisation des moyens financiers
et on a une part de TVA on a des
dotations qui sont livrées au
collectivité locale donc la main de
l'État est là et qui définit les
conditions et les moyens et les
ressources à la disposition des
collectivités locales donc le gouvern
est t avec la taxe d'habitation avec la
fin de la CVAE la tax d'habitation la
taxe d'habitation soyons clair c'est un
engagement unilatéral pris par le
président Macron à l'occasion de
l'élection présidentielle de dire on
enlève l'impôt local il est compensé au
départ pas dans la durée parce qu'on
voit qu'il y a effectivement des pertes
en ligne soit sur les bases soit sur les
volumes et donc c'est détestable la CVAE
qui a été retardé en terme voilà de
d'accélération tax sur la valeur ajoutée
sur les entreprises pour dire là aussi
même même même topo donc à un moment on
peut pas prenner la décentralisation la
confiance des EU locaux sans leur donner
les marges de manœuvre euh nécessaires
et aussi maintenir un lien puissant
entre celles et ceux qui élisent les
élus locaux et celles et ceux qui
exercent les collec dans les
collectivités locales le pouvoir c'estàd
les élus et il y a un contrat politique
mais aussi un contrat fiscal le contrat
fiscal passe par l'impôt local merci
Quentin à tout à l'heure merciien oui je
reviens dans le club on parlera
effectivement de ce double revers pour
les alr cette semaine sur le projet de
loi immigration sur le texte immigration
ce sera à suivre dans le club on va chez
vous on va g dans les Hautes Alpes
retrouver Fabrice margaillant merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Fabrice
directeur des départemental du dauphinet
libéré dans les Hautes Alpes et les
Alpes du Sud on va revenir avec vous
Fabrice sur la visite hier de la
ministre Dominique fort venue rencontrer
les sinistrés des
intempéries tout à fait euh d'abord si
vous permettez j'ai une question pour
pour monsieur le sénateur euh monsieur
sénateur les plus importantes de la
semaine dernière ont fait des dégâts
très importants à gu dans les environs
euh emportant des routes habillement des
infrastructures des bâtiments privés ou
communaux comment est-ce qu'on peut
accompagner les les élus locaux et les
aider eux qui sont toujours en première
ligne d'abord en étant présent
lorsqu'ils sont confrontés à des
catastrophes ou à des situations
exceptionnelles comme je l'étais durant
tout ce weekend dans le gu trakera
ensuite derrière et après la période
d'émotion et finalement de d'engagement
physique j'ai j'ai vu des élus pleurer
par l'émotion par également la fatigue
de leur engagement euh travailler à à la
reconstruction immédiate cela passe
d'abord par la reconnaissance de
catastrophe naturelle je crois savoir
que au moins pour les trois principales
communes que sont guest r guilier rizou
cela devrait être inscrit à la
commission qui évalue les dossiers pour
classification de catastrophe naturelle
le 12 décembre prochain j'ai d'ailleurs
fait des démarches en ce sens et puis la
ministre a dit hier une chose importante
je souhaite simplement que ces propos
soient transformer en acte elle a dit
qu'il n'y aurait aucun reste à charge
pour les Collectiv locale confronté à
ces catastrophes j'entends je je ferais
en tant que parlementaire puisque nous
avons aussi un pouvoir d'évaluation et
de contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
je je je m'astraindrai un devoir de
suite des propos tenus par Dominique
fort et faire en sorte effectivement que
l'autofinancement de ces travaux ne soit
pas à la charge des collectivités
locales parce qu'ell ne pourront rien
faire d'autre et je ne suis même pas sûr
pour les plus petites d'entre elles
qu'elles seront en capacité
d'autofinancer lorsqu'on aura déjà fait
le bilan des travaux d'urgence les
premières estimations qui m'ont été
rapportées par le président de la comité
de commune du guillro Dominique moulin
et par Marcel canal le conseiller
départemental vice-président en charge
des infrastructures c'est de l'ordre de
20 millions d'euros pour des territoires
ruraux de montagne c'est un mur un mur
de financement et et je pense
effectivement nécessaire d'avoir une
solidarité d'État et puis la dernière
chose que je peux dire aussi euh à
plusieurs reprises sur les phénomènes
d'inondation du nordpcalis des Haut-
de-fance euh des questions d'actualité
ont été posées à Christophe Béchu et il
a annoncé à plusieurs reprises la
perspective d'un décret favorisant le
curage des rivières et Canau je souhaite
d'abord dit que le texte a été envoyé au
Conseil d'État oui on attend le retour
j'étais avec le j'étais en contact avec
le cabinet du du du ministre hier pour
l'instant on attend le retour j'espère
simplement que ce curage des canaux et
rivièr en zone de Plain sera élargi aux
zones de montagne parce qu' il y a un
vrai sujet de de traitement de
l'engravement de nos torrents de
montagne et les sont bien souvent
aujourd'hui presque au niveau de
l'engravement des torents de montagne et
lorsque nous avons aujourd'hui à
intervenir avec les collectivités on a
souvent de la part de l'administration
la DDT l'ofb des procédures qui sont
parfois et qui bloque tout et je pense
qu'il faut avancer sur ce sujet un mot
des avec vous Fabrice pardon vous avez
une question pour Jean-Michel sur les
oui de choses monsieur monsieur le
sénateur locaux ont présenté leur leur
volonté de faire de ces gios des gios
vertueux et de profiter de ces GI pour
lutter pour rattraper en fait le
problème de de désenclavement du
brillant sonnet est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est une réelle opportunité pour
voy sonn et surtout que cette volonté de
faire des Jos vertueux suffira à
rassurer les oppositions bon d'abord je
crois qu'il faut se
réjouir que la France soit en capacité
après 2024 les gos d'été de pouvoir
organiser des gios divivers c'est une
opportunité pour la montagne française
moi j'entends des opposants il y en aura
toujours et et des radicalités extrêmes
sur ces sujets on en connaît sur
d'autres d'autres thématiques je dis
simplement que vaut mieux organiser des
Jos dans les ales françaises que des Jos
y compris divers en Arabie Saoudite non
mais je je dis ça avec un peu d'humour
mais à un moment on aura plus de
capacité à maîtriser l'impact
environnemental avec ces jou ou bien il
faut dire que la vision du monde que
nous avons toutes et tous dans tous les
cas ces radicalité c'est de dire on
arrête des événements internationaux or
il me semble que la vertu du sport même
si radicalité c'est les écologistes pour
vous pas pas les écologistes de manière
g des ultra radicaux c'està dire qu'il y
a ycompris chez les écologistes des
nuances hein il y a toutes les couleurs
des gris hein ou des Verts hein dans
dans dans les écomes d'ailleurs dans
dans toutes les sensibilités je parle de
celles et ceux qui sont contre tout et
qui veulent finalement revenir à à à à
un monde de décroissance et et un monde
de replil sur soit donc une fois que
j'ai dit ça pour les Hautes Alpes c'est
une et pour les Alpes françaises mais
parulièrement pour les Hautes Alpes euh
c'est une opportunité pour travailler
sur la sécurisation de nos résaux
routiers et on a sur la RN 94 qui
traverse le département du Nord au Sud
du des travaux à faire pour faciliter la
fluidité y compris que Don pourront
bénéficier les mobilités du quotidien on
a un objectif fixé par le président de
Région de rendre je le dis pour les pour
les téléspectateurs qui ne connaissent
pas les haut des Alpes 5h pour faire 250
km entre Marseille et Briançon en train
l'objectif c'est de le faire en 3 He
donc il y a un travail à faire pour
faciliter les sillons et les croisements
de sillon sur le chemin de fer et avoir
effectivement une mobilité plus
vertueuse avec le chemin de fer on a un
travail à faire en matière de formation
pour les jeunes pour rendre nos
territoires attractif et enfin on a une
résilience une transformation de nos
logements qui sont des passoirs
énergétiques beaucoup de logements mais
aussi des logements qu'il faut rénover
je pense que tout ça peut être un
phénomène d'accélération avec les Jos et
ça fait beaucoup de défis et on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler évidemment
merci merci beaucoup je Michel Arnaud
d'avoir été avec nous on mercie
également Fabrice on regarde la une du
dauphinet libéré édition des Hautes
Alpes c'est la disparition du petit
Émile 5 mois après pourquoi l'enquête
est aussi complexe c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup à tous les
deux on accueille notre prochaine invité
patri stéphanini